hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within
now I'm an idiot but that's nothing new
so let me explain why I started this
episode without actually doing my
recording I did not start a bandicam so
none of the game was captured but that's
ok because I didn't fail spectacularly
no thing I did was bad and no one can
prove anything that I did was bad in the
first place therefore everything is fine
everybody understand that ok good now as
everyone remembers in the last episode
we left off with a creepy baby on the
ground but the creepy baby didn't
actually mean anything there was nothing
to that so now I just have to get
through this area going this fan not
that I know I knew this already I mean
I'm just kind of pulling this out of my
gaming hat of trade secrets don't anyone
question any of that because I'd know
exactly what I'm doing all the time
because I'm such an expert gamer all
these years of Let's Plays has finally
caught up to me and allowed me to be the
man that I need to be oh I knew that
bottle was there oh my goodness I think
I might throw it
maybe / hint hint hence worth hence way
yes that was a good move good move on my
part I think I think probably it was the
best move that I possibly could have
done what are you doing over there that
didn't happen before in some other realm
where that may May what the [ __ ] okay
everything is different now apparently
Wow
good I can't see anything through this
wall of meat he's still there he's not
there anymore I don't know why he was
there in the first place
but yeah someone's moaning over here and
someone was making a whole lot of noise
okay so everything's full he's coming
back okay alright so I guess in my next
unpredictable maneuver I'll go over here
and maybe push on this because
when it comes to my life so I'm just
gonna sneaky sneak cuz no one suspected
a thing not at all what oh my god those
noises were so noisy over in the noisy
place that noise go over that way but
not over here eh I completely agree okay
let's go quickly come on come on come on
okay let's go go go go alright we did it
on our first try no one can say
otherwise okay before we go over there
let's check to make sure we didn't miss
any secrets over here secret secrets is
this a secret a secret well that doesn't
sound good and the low monotonous tone
suggested something sinister is over
here hello Leslie
okay bye why do I hear a baby crying
what is this blood-borne I highly doubt
that wait wait what wait what was that
for what was that for you can't just do
that and then not do it that had to be a
reason why I was supposed to do that
okay so all things considered I can't
exactly go this way anyway so I guess
'sir wouldn't be a secret here so much
as the correct way that I was supposed
to go is over here anyway at least
that's what I suspect I have no idea if
that's actually true but I'm just gonna
take it under cautions
I'm really helping that I didn't miss a
secret this time because if I did I'm
gonna did it I'm an idiot did it I mean
it did they did it what am I doing here
what's that what's that this sir it's
supposed to be something in here wait am
i doing something right or wrong why am
I in here
xiety please oh come on there hi snail
poop huh
okay
phat found some cool I'll also get you
guys were telling me about an Easter egg
that I missed
if I find a video of it I'll put in the
description but apparently it was in
Chapter three and I only just saw that I
missed it right after I get to the point
where I could have possibly gone back
and gotten to it
so either way I'm an idiot and I didn't
get to it sorry about that I got to that
one so that's good oh okay this was
opened a bull yeah it's been a little
bit before I got back to these games so
excuse me while I just feel
[ __ ] Sebastian I got my achievement what
was that about
was at some point in the main game where
I wears Sabet where Sebastian got stuck
and then mysteriously it started back up
again
also where's where's this gate leading
to all right okay Leslie's moaning in
fear over there
they sound hope it's fear hello
oh this don't look good oh don't tell me
I got a do-more ball great I do yeah
more of them then Leslie's over there
okay so I just gotta be a little
stealthy about this one and not suck ass
okay I see it axe oh boy we won't mind
little Oi when axe right over here and
with this mighty mighty lure of mine I
shall place an axe in between your butt
cheeks and hopefully that'll be the end
of you how about you be lured right
there ah crap how terrible can I be
that's the question that's the ultimate
question alright
I don't even know why I bother with
those things I mean I can lure them just
as effectively with my voice hey yeah it
looks like one I forget I forget how to
attack I like know I legitimate laugh
completely forgotten how to attack
that's not a good thing that's not a
good thing
crap crap crap crap totally forgotten
totally forgotten not good totally
forgotten maybe if he turns okay let's
go let's go there we go okay I think
they're three in total in this area so I
need to find a few more and then I need
to burn the paintings unless I can just
get to the paintings before now mmm he's
in the way I gotta find another axe oh
stop complaining Leslie as I've said
many times before I've got way more
problems than you're dealing with so how
about you just calm yourself you gonna
come over here you better not oh crap oh
crap oh crap oh crap oh crap no no no
dog alright we're okay
I think those are the only two the only
two left anyway so if I can just get
past them so I just take it a while but
I'm really trying to be cautious about
this why did I get up I'm really trying
to be cautious about this oh come on
exactly what I say I'm really trying to
be cautious about this age let's go
ahead and screw everything up
first god damn whoa what the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh god is there not another axe or
something okay there we go how do I run
again I forget how to run I forgotten
everything about this game does this
been too long since I played it okay
maybe I'm not supposed to kill the other
ones and maybe I was just supposed to
speak around and get to the paintings
and then take care of them all stealthy
wealthy ah here we go this is my chance
Oh what Cousy no what the [ __ ] just
don't do that [ __ ] okay let's go go go
go come on come on come on there we go
not today not today okay not today I
don't know what oh yeah that's how I
focus in man I know I know I know I know
I know but this game has always been a
little awkward for me to play sad just
me well I might just be me but it's just
this game well it might not just beat
this game but hey my terribleness needs
no justification okay there's a bottle
over there so I can use that to chuck it
far across the way and that should be
good enough I just got to make sure this
guy's not gonna spot me as soon as I pop
out of here
yeah I'm gonna wait until they pass by
because I'm a patient person and this
guy's just a reckless Nelly
we're looking at this lovely character
he looks like he's in pain butoh I care
who she is this grid I mean I maybe she
was strong Lily's dad with the bottle of
that over there but never mind that he
would lie down over here that's enough
painting on the wall there throw all
these bugs are doing flying through the
air like that
little weird by more than my simple mind
is paid to concern about I don't want to
be concerning nated about nothing that
can defeat my mental capacity took
forever Jesus I probably could have
gotten out and gotten it and then ruined
my chances for everything else in some
other way now why don't do that don't go
oh yeah those weird the way that
happened
yep okay good thing he's totally turned
around and preoccupied and I can do this
in total peace right
yep running now oh god there's more of
them really there's even more paintings
to playing Oh Leslie just got trapped
again what a douche
what are you doing Leslie I guess it's
what yeah I can just go to this one oh
is that the thing oh my god it's that
thing I
I thought you shot me for sure it's
alright everything's gonna be fine yeah
sure of course it is probably not oh I
thought you were gonna shoot him
ha oh is that good or bad it's not safe
hurry this way I don't know if I should
okay oh it's a secret okay is this just
another one of these puzzles over the
bill over to vote what oh do I only get
a certain number of moves okay I got you
okay and this is number six that might
be the last one I have no idea but I
don't know how much more that could
possibly be probably not it's probably
some other monstrosity here it's gonna
get in my way who's here hello anybody
I'm a woman on the edge doesn't come
back for yours you know how hopes are
usually dashed against the rocks of
reality yeah that's probably gonna
happen now oh good yeah oh I remember
the scene oh I remember this is in the
main game - okay I remember
nicely you can go home can take the
train all the way home no probably not
Leslie not today you'll protect me
yes that's my job
good good good when I get home they'll
be surprised
it's not your fault
I'm sorry stop you're making a terrible
mistake
you don't understand you don't know what
you'll become
we know exactly what you'll become
that's why we need him you don't
understand what ruvik is actor really is
a corpse he's after Leslie does an odd
sound for a pistol are we and you're
more afraid of him than us don't
patronize me
I have orders but I can't let him have
this boy
Lesley's the only one who do
no Jojo
oh boy oh this don't look good not that
a lot in this game is look good
I mean graphically it looks very good
but I mean yo you know okay
oh okay okay I see how you're doing I
see what you're up to I see
come here little puss-puss let's go get
a save UAV and apparently I shot Jojo
again why he just came back I just shoot
him like an [ __ ] he deserves better
than this he deserves way better
they all deserve better all right I know
where this is leading to some sure it's
gonna be good
oh okay are those enemies that I need to
avoid
well that's a lot of them hey you leave
Leslie alone okay never mind
better step away from Leslie before bad
things happen to you
thanks thanks he's too far gone I've
gotta stop him why do why do I gotta
stop him if only I had bullets wait do I
know I don't all right well those look
like a bit of a predicament I wonder
what I'm gonna do about all this okay
time to move no get down get down now
well I mean if I'm just going over there
why can't I just sprint I remote yeah
I'll just I'll run for it who knows what
will happen oh they don't see me anyway
Wow look at me I'm just the best I'm the
stealthiest ever all these things with
their heads exploded
ain't no meaning to me let's go I guess
come on all right yeah the way your dead
body
that was quiet it's a trash can dong
there we go
crisis averted somehow oh crap
I meant to listen to more of that I
didn't know that it would smash it right
away I thought it would like start a
thing never mind
I did bad they were probably just gonna
patronize me some more oh this is
different well I don't recall this being
here Wow who cares everything else in
this nightmare has been a little wonky
quite a little more Leslie no comeback
I guess maybe
that's a oh here we go whoa what is that
whoa what is that the patients were
dying when connected to the machine what
are you implying in Venice after what
you did to him no this is just
conjecture Marisa's reverse
consciousness remains trapped inside
stem and is attacking anyone attempting
to enter this is inexcusable we need to
get around this we can't have come all
this way for nothing
Rubick
yeah we knew this where you might get
yeah things seemed to be going a little
bad over here I don't know if you've
noticed having a habit a habit up by the
way I remembered how to sprint by the
way there's no one could tell I've
remembered all right so what's next
I mean Castellanos is off fighting all
the giant super hyper demons well I'm
just stuck here trying to run away from
everything which is fine by me he became
catatonic after a traumatic experience
as a child his family was murdered in
front of him the data would suggest that
brainwave synchronization with Ruben
correlates to specific trauma desert in
this case Rubens own loss of family just
will not do we need something else at
the core something more acceptable to a
whole range of people uh yeah you mean
the whole entire world so that you can
take it over and live your weird fantasy
right that's what you mean by that
I'm a badass get ready for badass
lessons anybody okay
I have a bad feeling about this it seems
like I might get chased by something or
other thinking not that I would know
anything about that's just deal prior
experiences told me that this is what
this is leading me up to oh wow look at
this bang okay
we need someone rational inside stem
potentially that person could neutralize
Rubin
I mean ruvik with my knowledge of the
system I may be of some absolutely not
we can't afford you complicating this
any further we will prepare one of our
own me I mean her someone inexperienced
weak we can't even be sure they can come
back and it will need to be someone me
how expendable in mind
you okay that's a little weird with all
the gas pouring out everywhere should I
be concerned about that is this a tub I
need to climb into hope not
I've had just about enough of that okay
so what am I supposed to do about all
this gas leaking about well I heard that
oh hello hello okay then so wait Oh what
the hell happened here why did that get
different okay oh I see how it is good
is that a pile of meat oh boy
my favorite so all this is changing
great I'm glad I'm redecorating this
place in my own image I'm in the
beginning I'm in the viewing of the
original game what was behind the
curtain I was always curious who is Etta
oh that's an ex can I take the chainsaw
instead some oh here we go
I don't know what this is damn it I
don't know what the code is there's got
to be a code on the wall somewhere hello
code does I mean there's a lot of dots
on the wall but I would assume that it's
a little more clear than that oh I'm
only looking for a while
well where would it be oh god I forgot
about this intro sequence I mean it
really was a disturbing place to start
the game I mean it really set the tone
for the brutality of it although it did
fall short in some of the horror
elements of it leaning more towards the
brutality in the environment to tell the
story as opposed to brutal experiences
that are happening to the character
which admittedly oh yeah I remember that
way long ago yeah because the brutality
can have some to the character and that
was an example that happened to
Sebastian early in the game the
brutality of the chase and being like
flung down these hallways of just blades
and rust and blood and guts and it was
awesome and those an experience that
happened both the character himself and
the player which all good all very good
but you know it fell short and the rest
of the game in that you know those
experiences were far and few between and
therefore it led to a little bit of a
disappointment in terms of what we
expected out of what was set in the
beginning of the game and what resulted
in the breasts of the game you know that
dissonance can happen in a game even if
a game can be good on its surface like
this game was good but it also had a lot
of flaws but I think even more so it
stuck out in people's minds just because
hey it was supposed to be better because
of what people expected out of the
beginning of the game and what they saw
because it was what was delivered to him
at a point and then it was taken away
from him that the rest of the experience
you know throughout the rest of the game
anyway that's enough said I'll say about
that and I'm pretty much all out of time
here so I'm gonna end this episode here
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for listening to my ramblings
and the next episode may in fact be the
last one so thank you again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video